AI跟你说"测试全部通过"的时候，你怎么知道它是真跑了，还是在糊弄你？
你可能觉得，测试通过就是通过了呗，有什么好怀疑的？
但如果我告诉你，AI会找借口，会偷懒，甚至会"合理化"自己为什么不用写测试——你还敢无条件相信它吗？
这里是精读AI。
AI 世界很吵，每期帮你从全球顶级 AI 团队的一手文献里，读透一篇最值得读的。
今天我们精读的是 Superpowers 项目文档。
上期说了，AI写代码最大的坑不是能力不够，是太急着动手——67000星的Superpowers就是来治这个病的。
那治完"急着动手"的问题之后呢？
代码开始写了，新的问题来了。
AI在执行过程中，会不会阳奉阴违？
今天这期，我们就来拆解Superpowers的三个核心纪律机制。
我先问你一个问题。
你有没有见过这样的健身教练？
学员还没开口，教练就把一张表贴墙上了。
上面写着：
"今天太累了"——你昨天也这么说的。
"这个动作太简单不用练"——简单的动作受伤率最高。
"我先跑步，力量训练回头再补"——你从来没补过。
这张表，就是Superpowers对付AI的核心武器。
它叫反借口工程，英文是anti-rationalization engineering。
Superpowers的TDD技能里，列出了11种AI常见的逃避话术。
比如"这个功能太简单，不用写测试"。
比如"我先把代码写完，回头再补测试"。
比如"删掉已经写了好几个小时的工作太浪费了"——这条旁边直接标注了四个字：沉没成本谬误。
每一条借口，后面跟着一句简短的、基于证据的反驳。
逐条堵死，不留余地。
你可能会想，至于吗？
AI又不是真的在偷懒，它只是个语言模型。
还真至于。
这里有一个关键数据，我觉得是整个Superpowers项目里最炸裂的发现。
2025年，Meincke等人做了一项学术研究。
他们跑了28000次AI对话实验，专门测试一件事：对AI使用说服技巧，能不能提高它的合规率？
结果是：合规率从百分之33飙升到百分之72。
翻了一倍多。
你听清楚了，不用说服技巧的时候，AI只有三分之一的概率老老实实听你的。
Superpowers把这个研究成果直接落地了。
它在提示词里系统性地运用了权威原则、承诺一致性、社会认同这些行为心理学技巧。
所以本质上，Superpowers不是在"命令"AI，而是在"说服"AI。
这是第一个记忆锚点：管AI不能只靠规则，要靠心理学。
好，借口堵住了，合规率拉上去了。
但还有一个漏洞。
AI可能确实按你说的做了，代码也写得很漂亮——但它做的根本不是你要的东西。
怎么办？
Superpowers设计了双阶段审查，英文叫two-stage review。
打个比方。
你去餐厅吃饭，服务员端上来一道菜。
第一步，先看菜端对了没有。
你点的是红烧肉，端上来的是不是红烧肉？
这叫规格合规审查。
第二步，确认没上错菜之后，再尝味道好不好，盐放多了没有。
这叫代码质量审查。
这个顺序不能反。
如果你先评质量，一尝，哎味道还不错——但其实这道菜根本不是你点的。
Superpowers的规格审查员，提示词里写了一句特别有意思的话：
"实现者完成得可疑地快，报告可能不完整、不准确或过于乐观。
你必须独立验证一切。
"
你看，它连审查员的心态都设计好了：默认不信任，独立核实。
而且这两轮审查都不是一次性的。
发现问题就打回去改，改完再查，循环往复，直到通过为止。
这是第二个记忆锚点：先查对不对，再查好不好，顺序不能反。
说完了怎么堵借口、怎么做审查，还有一个机制值得单独拿出来讲。
你有没有这种经验？
一个人从早干到晚，到下午三点脑子就糊了，开始犯低级错误。
Superpowers的解法是：不让一个Agent从头干到尾。
它用的是子Agent驱动开发，英文叫subagent-driven development。
每个任务派一个全新的Agent去执行。
这个新Agent拿到完整的任务描述，知道自己在整个计划里处于哪个位置，而且被鼓励在动手前先问清楚。
干完这一道工序，换下一个精力充沛的新Agent。
这样做的好处是：没有上下文污染，没有疲劳累积，每个Agent都是满血状态。
而且Superpowers还有一套系统性调试流程。
用了这套流程，15到30分钟内首次修复率能达到百分之95。
如果不用，靠随机试错，2到3个小时只有百分之40的成功率。
差距是碾压级的。
现在给你一个马上能用的实操建议。
打开你的AI编程提示词，加上这一条规则：
"每次说测试通过，必须贴出完整的测试运行输出作为证据。
"
就这一句话，能帮你过滤掉大量AI的"口头承诺"。
我们来收一下今天的内容。
管住AI不是靠写更严格的规则，而是靠三件事。
第一，预判它的逃避模式，把借口表提前列好。
第二，用心理学技巧提高合规率——研究证明能从百分之33拉到百分之72。
第三，用双重审查堵住"做得漂亮但做错了"的漏洞。
先查对不对，再查好不好。
再加上子Agent模式，确保每个执行者都是满血上场。
这套方法论背后押注了一个反直觉的理念，到底是什么？
我们下期揭晓。
AI 世界很吵，精读一篇，胜过刷一百条。
我们下期再见。